there are thousands of stars known to
science today
and they are scattered across the entire
universe
as a rule the stars we know are regular
ones that fall into this
or that clearly defined class
however sometimes we come across some
really fascinating objects whose
properties are not that easy to explain
one of these celestial bodies is myra a
dying star
traveling at an unbelievable speed one
of its
peculiar features is its tail which
stretches out for several light years
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
most stars in the milky way slowly
revolve around the center of the galaxy
their appearance is rather recognizable
and their speed is approximately the
same as that of interstellar gas
our sun for example passes through the
local interstellar cloud at a speed of
about 25 kilometers per second
but myra really stands out in this
respect as it whizzes through gas in
interstellar space at a speed of 130
kilometers per second
as a result of such staggering
propulsion the shed material is blown
back
thus forming the unique tale we can
marvel at
this tale is the feature that makes myra
one of the most peculiar stars in the
cetus constellation
the tale of this star was discovered in
2007 with the help of the galax
orbiting ultraviolet space telescope
a group of astronomers received high
quality ultraviolet light images of myra
where the tail made up of gas and dust
can be clearly seen
at first this stale formation rather
perplexed the scientists
as the star had been under observation
for over 400 years
and no tail had been spotted before but
the riddle was soon solved
only ultraviolet images were able to
reveal the tail
and only regular photos had been taken
before
the length of the tail reaches 13 light
years
which is three times the distance from
the sun to the closest star
proxima centauri as i've already
mentioned it was formed by material
being shed in the course of the star's
movement through space
every 10 years myra sheds approximately
as much material as the mass of our
earth
by estimating the length of the tail in
the star's velocity
the material found at the very tip of
the tail was gauged to have been dumped
as long ago as about
30 000 years as for the total mass of
the material shed so far
it may be as much as three thousand
earth masses
marvelous as it is the tail isn't the
only feature that singles out myra among
other stars
another feature it has is a bizarre
formation that can also be seen in
images beamed back from the galax
telescope
it most likely originated as a result of
myra's speed with which it travels
through the molecular cloud
a kind of bow we can see in front would
have been accumulated in the many years
as a result of the star's material at
the front colliding with particles of
interstellar gas
that makes myra resemble a boat cutting
through water
only myra cuts through space instead
most of the shed material is made up of
atoms of hydrogen
once shed they gradually lose their
impetus and release the energy in the
form of ultraviolet rays
and it is these rays that were captured
by the galax telescope
we know mira as a binary pulsating
variable star
in its maximum luminosity periods it
flares up to be the brightest star in
its constellation
but even with its luminosity at its
lowest it can still be seen through
regular binoculars
the best time for observing it from our
earth is october and november
billions of years ago this object used
to be a yellow dwarf
and today myra's stellar travels are
coming to an end
as it is now in one of the final stages
of a star's life
speaking about its system it comprises
two stellar companions
myra a a red giant and myra b
a white dwarf both objects are about 417
light years away from our earth
and the distance between the companions
themselves is 70 astronomical units
the first component in the system is a
pulsating variable star
with the average apparent magnitude 3.5
depending on the phase however the value
may fluctuate between
10 and 2.
just to compare the apparent magnitude
of sirius
is minus 1.46
the mass of the system's first component
is approximately 1.2 that of the sun
interestingly its radius is 360 times
that of the sun
the reason for such impressive
dimensions and a comparatively small
mass
lies in the fact that since mira a is a
red giant
its average density may be thousands of
times less than that of water
just to compare the average density of
the sun is slightly bigger than that of
water
besides a star hitting the red giant
phase gets a massive growth spurt
and with a mass comparable to that of
the sun may in theory grow to the size
of the earth's orbit
the surface temperature on mira a
reaches 3000 degrees kelvin
the luminosity of the star meanwhile is
9000 times that of the sun
as for its supposed age it is estimated
to be 6 billion years
the red giant is not massive enough to
go supernova at the end of its life
cycle
instead it is going to expel its outer
envelope and gradually turn into a white
dwarf
the expanding outer envelope forms a
planetary nebula which will later on be
dispersed in space around it
as for the second component mira b it is
a white dwarf already
as this object is located close to mira
a by space standards
it attracts material dumped from the
outer layers of the red giant
in this manner a hot accretion disk was
formed around myra b
and since mata is shed onto it at
irregular intervals
mira is a variable star too its apparent
magnitude fluctuates between 9.5
and 12. thus
both components in the system are
variable stars or variables
stars in the universe whose luminosity
depends on physical processes taking
place in their vicinity
also fall into the same category
it is important to study these objects
in order to understand the nature of
stellar evolution
as variable stars are more often than
not at a turning point in their
existence
in fact the phenomenon of myra is a
perfect demonstration of how objects
reaching some milestone or rather in
their life
may conceal a number of great riddles
myra's unusual features allowed
scientists to use it as the prototype
for a special classification for such
like objects that got the name
myra type stars or mira variables
celestial objects of this variety are
pulsating variable stars of late type
spectral classes
with the values for their apparent
magnitudes ranging from 2.5 to
mira variables are giants that shed
their router envelope in the course of
several million years
and eventually turn into white dwarfs
mostly myra type variables shouldn't be
heavier than two masses of the sun
although they may be thousands of times
brighter than the sun
on account of their expanded outer layer
the pulsation of these objects
occurs due to regular contraction and
expansion of these stars
this also causes changes in the radius
and temperature
resulting in variable luminosity as for
the chance of planets possibly hiding
somewhere in these stars orbits only one
myra type variable boasts an unconfirmed
planetary system
aleonis in the leo constellation
it goes without saying that the
information about myra possessed by
science today
is rather sparse we really have no clue
if there are planets or some equally
amazing space
objects located close to it but it is
safe enough to say that this star is yet
to hit the headlines
and for all we know it may happen
literally at any moment
if you'd like to be the first to be
updated on this one
stay with the cosmo channel and feel
free to subscribe to our channel in
telegram
where we post the latest scientific news
dear friends i hope you enjoy the stuff
we share about all those celestial
bodies in space
if you'd like to support our project in
addition to a like or a comment
feel free to follow the link to patreon
it's in this video's description
your encouragement motivates us to carry
on making new videos about awesome
objects in space
and as you watch our channel keeps
growing
let's keep in touch
[Music]
you